el juez matthew brand dio la opción de
que el estado de las autoridades
electorales de ese estado pudieran
certificar los más de 80.000 votos que
yo bailé tiene de ventaja contra donald
trump y así entonces pues se les sumaría
los estados que ya certifican los votos
de estados como georgia que también este
fin de semana certificó los votos hay
que mencionar que pues con esta decisión
del juez pues es una nueva derrota para
la campaña de donald trump para el
partido republicano que además ajusta 31
derrotas en cortes por demandas de
fraude electoral de supuesto fraude
electoral y es que este juez dice que la
campaña de un autor no presentó
evidencias sólidas para justificar esta
acusación y además dos firmas de donald
trump se han retirado ya y pues 24
demandas que había interpuesto esta
campaña donald trump han sido retiradas
yorley michigan también podríamos
esperar resultados de hoy sobre la
certificación de estos resultados y así
entonces pues
a los argumentos de trampa para darle
más opciones y más tiempo a job aiden de
empezar la transición cristóbal
entretanto yobái de no podría nombrar
muy pronto a su secretario de estado que
se sabe del nominado anthony blinken
pues es un veterano de la política
exterior en eeuu de hecho durante el
gobierno de barack obama fue el
secretario de estado adjunto también
trabajó en la oficina también como
asesor del presidente obama ex
presidente tiene 58 años estudió leyes
en harvard ese grado también de un
posgrado en la universidad de columbia
su padre fue inversor en wall street
también fue embajador en hungría este
señor pues fue periodista blinken
también durante un periodo corto y pues
se espera que sea un funcionario
moderado algo que ayudaría para que el
congreso el senado que es de mayoría o
sería de mayoría republicana pues lo
apruebe fácilmente dos nombramientos que
se podrían venir también jake sullivan
que sería el de la asesor nacional de
seguridad y también linda thomas que
sería para eeuu
la embajadora en las naciones unidas